liberté nous voulons la liberté scandale
de Shanghai sorti pour une vigile à la
chandelle qui s'est transformée en
manifestation rassemblée sur la rue qui
porte le nom doromtchi les manifestants
ont fini par être dispersés par la
police avant l'aube il y a quelques
jours l'intervention des services
d'incendie de la capitale du Chine
aurait été ralenti à cause des
restrictions sanitaires et 10 personnes
sont mortes
ce tristement soulevé un mouvement
populaire contre les mesures
draconiennes pour contrôler la pandémie
en Chine autant à roompy qu'ailleurs au
pays mais les rassemblements ont pris
une autre tournure dans les dernières
heures
la foule s'est mise à réclamé la
démission du président une revendication
extrêmement inhabituelle les chinois
sont rarement dissidents avec le régime
de Pékin ce qui a mené à des
arrestations durant la nuit
rien pour décourager les manifestants
qui sont aujourd'hui
et certains n'ont pas peur de se faire
arrêter comme cet homme qui brandit des
fleurs un symbole de protestation la
foule impuissante ne peut que crier et
filmer les actions des forces de l'ordre
le mouvement étudiant emboîte le pas ici
à la prestigieuse université chingua à
Pékin brandissant des feuilles blanches
symboles contre la censure les étudiants
ont également démontré leur hostilité
envers le président et le régime en
place
[Musique]
plus de la capitale chinoise sont aussi
devenues des lieux d'attroupement pour
les citoyens qui tiennent bien au des
feuilles blanches la force du nombre est
peut-être à faire sortir cette colère
qui gronde au sein de la population
chinoise et qui a émergé soudainement
avec les victimes de l'incendie de
romechi ici Carla Oliveira Radio-Canada
Montréal